did you know that upper Moon 4 huntengu
has seven different demon forms when
hunting who is attacked he doesn't just
die even if he loses his head instead he
multiplies into different demon forms
this includes sekido or anger who is
able to generate lightning karaku or Joy
who is able to generate wind isetsu or
sorrow who is able to generate deadly
Spears uroki or pleasure who is able to
fly and generate sound waves zohakuten
or hate who is able to generate and
manipulate wood urami or resentment who
is able to greatly increase his own size
and finally huntegu's True Form his true
form is able to hide its presence and
make itself extremely small no matter
how many times hantangu's clones are
killed they will never be defeated until
his true form is also destroyed for more
Demon Slayer content subscribe to anime
outpro right now Owen